hope everybody had an awesome weekend
welcome back to Sims and left coast [ __ ]
your weekend may my weekend was great
was it great mom's had her 60th birthday
happy birthday share my my birthday's
coming up and she gave me other picture
of me at the Super Bowl it's like with
my arms stretched out with the confetti
on the field on my desk right now so
every day I get to remind myself I'm a
Super Bowl champion yeah every day
should be good you're not married and
don't have kids you got a lot of [ __ ]
free time earlier it just sounds like to
me as a non kid haver when you have kids
you're just sitting there going this is
my life now yes they've taken all my
time when can I work out on a Sunday
I'll be in between baseball and
horseback riding sure I feel like the
phrase hey Dad watch me is like the
ultimate like when you're a child like
it's funny we've never talked about this
your face right now is incredible when
you're a kid you're just going no debt
pay attention to me what the f hear my
dad but it sounds like when you become a
dad hey Dad watch me hey Dad hey Dad can
you help me work hey Dad I'm hungry hey
Dad can you get the glass for me I need
some water
hey Dad you want to go outside and shoot
hoops hey Dad you want to play ball tag
hey hey so when you reach the point
where you're fed up and you can't be
like shut up like what do you do when I
can be yes I don't have the normal
technique or parent techniques that
maybe most do but I would say to most
you out there you have not raised the
Sims okay so men I've uh yeah I I swear
my kids a little you know that I'm harsh
with them at times very honest and I'm
not afraid I mean I it's been a while
but I'm not afraid to spank my kids a
little I think it's good yeah they need
it they do
Bob tired today man dude I can't imagine
like we had Hollin oh dude my wife
snored last night like and then she gets
mad at me see cuz you're not you need to
fake sleep what are you doing sleep I
want it real sleep no no what I'm saying
is you got a push back to sleep oh
you're right you're never like sitting
there pushing you're like your snore
because I've done the fake push and it
got me nowhere so I literally had to go
then I I can't hurt you I can't sleep I
can't sleep I can't say
how could you wake me up you stop waking
me up like screw you I haven't slept yet
no I go I go push and then I like roll
back over and I can't if I'm really done
yeah I'm done I'll tell you what so
because you're not on social media yes
because you're definitely not on the
Sims of left go account you're not
seeing all of the reactions right now
yes draft party's gonna be lit man cool
we have a wedding proposal that could
happen I saw I saw so we have a few fans
one fan reached out and said is it cool
if I propose to my girlfriend and then
followed up with she literally is going
around the house saying whoa big off
season which is by the way coming back
so whoa off season starts today we're
also going to get into a nice little
dilemma that's around the NFL in terms
of how do you transition quarterbacks we
also have a nice deep dive into the
Patriots another segment slow news day
it's all coming back so it's gonna be
good but yet we even had one person say
darn I wanted to propose at the Sims
aleph coach draft party well there's no
limit your dad hasn't said it's not
happening there right no he is not I
don't want to go to my dad's house I
mean now that my dad was blown away I
don't think he's realizes what he got
himself into I even said that to him the
other day cuz he was talking about it
again on the phone and I was like he's
still he's excited about he doesn't know
what he's saying he's just like oh the
drop next year and I was like that
you're gonna have strangers like we're
gonna have a thousand people at your
house and what he said it's gonna be
that big huh yeah it is dad I don't know
if you want to really do this I want to
sell it I mean he would have a great
setup for it we could do it it's so
excited even when you talk about how
ridiculous would be you always end it
with but it would be pretty cool yeah
well they got the setup they got I mean
we have fans that have deemed us saying
I am a Lions fan I will come to the
party I will drive from Detroit and I
will dress like a lion and I
fight somebody dressed as a bear like we
are having people and I'm like yes got
fights or a thing it's a thing by the
way the new mascot fight coming at you
at the end of the episode so stay tuned
for that the other thing too that's
coming today or Wednesday oh no no we
pick it today due at the end so we had a
lot of people sending in before about
Sims in Madden 2006 oh we have now
gotten you in Madden 2011 on the Bronco
that's not good I want to know Ron goes
our Titans tige 2011 well I was guess I
was leaving the Broncos going to the
Titans so you're on the roster it's you
Tebow Brady Quinn and Kyle Orton yeah
yeah that's the fearsome foursome right
I shouldn't have been on that roster but
ok you are the lowest relative quit as
soon as they drafted Tebow just so you
know it's lowest rated player of the 4
yeah what do you think your overall was
so remember 2006 you were in 84 right
I'm gonna say 72 you were a 67 damn
that's really hard the 60 that is crappy
Tebow was a 69 ok nice Brady Quinn was a
70 right Kyle Orton was an 85 yeah well
let's see that year he ended up having a
good year I think you noticed and off
right yeah well that was oh wait oh 9 he
actually had some big passing number
games but yeah so I went through and I
really only cared about you and Tebow
right if his throwing powers more than
mine I might walk off the podcast we're
throwing accuracy with 71 right his was
71 that's disgusting I get throw better
with my right arm that he could his left
that's horrible
ok keep going what do you think your
throwing power was so what was it before
so then it's devolved of course truly I
mean my power didn't devolve totally but
gosh it was a long time since I played I
was so my power I'm gonna say 79-83 ok
what do you think t-bo's throwing
chopsticks probably made him more cuz I
could tell me this stupid grin on your
face they made him an 84 86 oh my gosh
that's so bad I had him throwing it
three points harder than you yes I just
knew that would be interesting yeah it's
very interesting
I feel like I want to sue sports for
false advertisement so what was really
funny though I have to figure out who
said this to me I need to give them the
respect but they also sent me that you
had insanely low kicking statistics
you're kicking accuracy was a nine yeah
and you're kicking power was a four I've
added everybody else was in like the 40s
and 50s but yours was really really a
you know those spleen injuries will
really screw up you're kicking prowess
let me just tell you I mean it takes
away the power kicking I first of all
when they asked me to be the holder I
was like no see you there like do you
have you ever hold held in your past you
want to hold I'm like no I don't so that
I always enter that kicking I mean I
don't know how to kick anything I never
played soccer I'm a straight toe ball
field goal kicker so I'll give Tebow
that the other stuff that's a shout out
to Luke Westcott for some awesome and it
also said that he was a better pass
blocker than you wow I can give them
that he can are you just gonna stand
there you want to come on with your like
an administrative assistant oh come here
come here I want to ask you something
really quick right so another thing
that's happening is apparently people
like Francis offend Rick yes and I just
want a little taste what we do in France
I said today are we talking Yankees Mets
what are we doing no the Yankees the
Yankees the number one team in the city
right it's Monday after the Derby would
leave with the Derby and the Preakness
preview that's all we do here no of
course I lived with it one day after the
Derby we talked Mets Yankees now Derby
I'm getting a little too Italian with it
I need to go back and more pure Francesa
I don't know I think that's pretty pure
though I'm treating he is Italian now
that this is I'm gonna have to go home
and practice this just I didn't get a
really good one other world of Simza
left go podcast our guy rod Simba yeah
Saul your coffee mug and a lot of people
saw the coffee mug Lovett art cent and
they were like wow that's fire and he
goes I want to make a jingle for the
coffee coffee mug okay so he actually
sent me three rod my jingle just of the
mug that we've reached Roger the man
big boys fan not great I'm cool with
that rod screw the Eagles so rod of the
three you picked my favorite to do the
jingle to was your third which is coffee
and crumpets so I'm gonna make it up on
the fly this is rod Simba and left go
doing a collaboration for Sims is coffee
mug do you wake up in the morning and
need a little pep in your step yes I do
Adam would you like to know which
quarterbacks ranked 45th of the NFL I
would like to then why don't you grab
yourself a nice big old sim 70 months
sounds interesting here at Sims a love
go we care not just about flavor but
football knowledge you can savor its the
sins football mug available on bleacher
report so that's where rod Simba's heads
at he is so deep in the weeds yeah
that's an old phrase deep in the weeds
yes that he's making jingles so rod
they're all great they are great that
was a good fitting appreciate you thanks
boss coming up at the end of the show we
had a chance to sit down or who did a
phone conversation with Minka
Fitzpatrick for 15-20 minutes and kind
of asked him what's it like to be Nick
Saban's favorite player of all time
right
who did he face in college that the
patented Simms question that he liked
just a great kid yeah later well
speaking of great people our guide Peter
King Pete King Peter King comes on our
podcast a few weeks ago and says I'm fed
up with this 24/7 and we thought that he
was just being grumpy old man no
apparently like he was in the midst of
leaving Sports Illustrated and now he's
gonna be doing pro football talk your
spot yeah yeah that's cool yeah he's
joining the squad there I think he's
still gonna write his like what his
weekly article the Monday oh that's such
a big deal and then he's gonna do one
show a week on Pro Football Talk so I
mean for me personally it's awesome I
mean it's good for the show
yeah and Peter you know as you've said
so many times has just an unbelievable
reach through the NFL it's wild not only
the amount of people that read his
columns and everything but just the
amount of people he knows coaches front
office people the little tidbits he can
share yeah so it's just a big mover and
shaker that is a big
the other mover I'm not sure I know he
went to Texas after you Michael Griffin
retired yeah I was wondering if that
made you feel old
no I yeah no not at all it does not make
me feel old your Texas brother
I know Grif got there right after me
it's one of those things where I think
there actually be calm in my heart when
everybody I played with or is done
playing to because I think there's one
thing like underneath my skin cell I
look at some guys I'm like man he's
still playing which are the guys I'm
sitting here talking to left go and
they're still playing which guys yeah I
mean gosh Eli's of the world Eli Tom
Brady certainly all of them those are
the guys that of course it's right in my
face all the time certainly and I just
go damn I was in Eli's class coming out
of high school he's still playing right
those kind of guys
so just guys I either played with went
to college with you know early in my
career still playing you know there'd be
like one part of your macallan it's like
yeah it would be like a door closed in
my life to finally feel like okay
finally it's the new page down for you
you go my eras done and then you're like
well I'm still going dude athletes are
sort of such a crazy life it is a great
talk about all the time but it's like
you guys like if you had to sit for
three years like Aaron Rodgers yeah that
could be like one third of your career
or one quarter of your career right and
you know but for us you know hey you
know heed your lay low for three years
okay I got like 50 more to go exactly
it's that's why you can't get mad at
players for want money and needing to
get paid right now you don't know and I
don't give a damn about their school
education or anything their strength in
life is the sport that they're playing
so they're gonna maximize what they can
do to help their family and monetize
that and I don't know that's the one
thing I don't understand in our culture
that argument all the time you know
people have strengths some people are
more athletic than smart some people are
more smart than that flooding but for
some reason with the athletic part we
get on everybody for it like oh how dare
they don't get their education but you
know nobody ever says that about the
tennis players nobody ever says it about
actors nobody ever says it about people
who are leading a band the lead singer
in a band nobody cares about their
education but damn athletes I think it's
because none of those people we don't
know their salaries like Matt Ryan we'll
talk about that later
hundred million dollars I know it
already yeah I don't know how much Tom
Cruise got for Mission Impossible 100
million for the one movie I don't know
how much I know you're right which is
that's your right and I think I'll just
say I think color has something to do
with that yes I do
color has something to do with it those
those those things we just mentioned are
not very culture eyes where we talk
about sports it is culture eyes it's
black there's a lot of black people of
course in baseball there's Spanish in
the literature crowd and yeah I think
that's part of the reason it's judged to
athletics are very diverse and they're
typically not the same percentages in
the normal population yeah but also the
athletes we feel the need to always
bring down yeah it's it's a weird floor
tell them how to live their life yeah
that's an interesting thing too well I
don't know if you guys have not been
listening to Sims the left go for a long
time welcome if you have welcome back it
is now time for whoa big offseason whoa
big offseason came around because every
year I would see these stories that were
very repetitive and there was a bunch of
different buckets for whoa big offseason
but I would see them and go okay let's
see if that actually turns into anything
I'll just tell the story again for
better part of my childhood
there was a wide receiver on the Eagles
named nay Brown and every offseason he
would go with the first week he would be
catching balls one-handed up top diving
and they go nay Brown may have finally
figured it out and every offseason I
would be like this is the year for nay
Brown and it never freakin happened Nene
so for me it's whoa big offseason we're
gonna first start off with the Dallas
Cowboys this is in the bucket of
little-known player buzz what's gonna
happen with Jason Witten being gone
don't worry no tight end on the roster
has received more praise from executive
vice president Stephen Jones then Blake
jar win whoa
Darwin was moved up to the active roster
last October after the Eagles showed
interest and right now the entire front
office of the Cowboys is buzzing about
Blake Darwin what are the odds that this
guy is actually a
I mean listen this is such a one-off
season because it's like fourth guy on
the depth chart we just lost a Hall of
Fame tied up we're gonna yeah we got
some propaganda from a guy in our area
that we think is a hidden gem
stay tuned for Blake Charlaine but
there's got to be some talent because
for them to keep them on the roster that
does go on right your egos wanted to
sign him off the roster yes they
obviously thought there was some
potential there again he's a guy that I
don't know a lot about so that's that's
why it's a woman I can't say much about
it I mean he I didn't study some of
those guys that came out in the draft
that you're that far down the line if
Blake charkh jar one ends up being good
he'll be the only cowboy I like because
it's just so such a funny name yeah
they're but they're not like slammed at
tight end you know the kid like the kid
Rico gathers we're all waiting to see
yeah I need to watch the all-or-nothing
Cowboys I had tweeted out that I was
gonna have a review today I don't know
if a bill for Wednesday either might do
it for next Monday but apparently there
was a scene where Rod Marinelli
is explaining how he wants to defend
Aaron Rodgers who so I'm gonna get that
clip but apparently it's like you can't
let him to the side she can't let him in
the back you need to keep him in the
well so it's got a lot of good stuff
I'll do like what I did for all or
nothing last year a full review and
speaking of Jason Witten the Monday
Night Football booth is official have
you heard I have I am very critical all
the time play-by-play Joe tessitura
color commenter color commentator Jason
Witten sideline reporter Lisa Salters
the only holdover and I think she's
actually fantastic she always has good
stories pregame in the middle and then
field analyst booger McFarland so
they're going like the Tony Siragusa
I guess so right I just didn't think of
all of your teammates on Tampa that
booger mcfarland would be the one on
television when all of a sudden I I
can't say that I did either I did not
see that one coming now he's a
knowledgeable sports fan he really loves
sports he definitely does got a
million-dollar smile I didn't never saw
this in his future either but he's made
a name for himself and obviously I mean
I seen him even on their new show get up
in the morning some in the mornings
they're so pretty crazy how people have
gravitated
- the nickname booger like his name is
Anthony oh I know and he bull he was a
player to people why is his name booger
I don't even know what the reason is
they called him booger groan but it's
something that was like childhood it
wasn't like something that gave to him
at the NFL he was always called booger
McFarlane phenomenal athlete I mean like
a a SAP type athlete but he had a lot of
injuries early on in his career that
really cost him of course one of the
things whenever I think of Booker
McFarland I think of him racing Sapp
that became a big deal tell that story
so he zap you know he thinks he's the
most athletic D lineman in football so
he's talking trash contraction boogers
finally he's like no I can I'm gonna
beat you in a 40 I'll beat you in a 40 I
can get out and booger everyone knows
booger is pretty explosive so when he
said that did the locker room just
explode days talking thing and then
finally Sapp like one day was an
operation and we like met a line in
practice so what's Gruden being like
come on man this is gonna be amazing
yeah they filmed it I mean they had all
like oh yeah booger gets in the blocks
right Warren gets in the blocks
I'm sure the energy there is palpable
everyone's excited did you bet who did
you pick oh I think was I think I
thought sap would just win I knew it
would be glasses this is like yours your
guy that hazed you yes your big bro so
you're kind of like nobody beats big bro
well I was just going awful like sap out
a little bigger calf muscles a little
bigger ass I was given the total Scout
that was given the whole scouting report
but booger like Sapp had the legs of a
man that was like a shutdown corner but
had the upper body of a diva has a
tackle so did you have Jon Gruden
dropping towels did you shoot a gun how
did it strength coach I believe Garrett
ghee MOT gave it like a full on your
marks get set go then take me through
the man booger
jumped out to the lead right off the bat
and never relinquished it that was it he
went wired he went to wire to wire
booger had phenomenal get off it's the
one thing I always say to people you
know about these D lineman in these
offensive linemen like hold on you're
going serious yeah the race ends the
race are they celebrating with booger or
was this the time for
everyone to talk crap to sound nobody
wanted to push the line of talk yes he
was heated everyone goes went to bugger
and was zapped you know which is over
there shaking his head or always saying
something to you do they ever have to go
for a second one or and stop talking so
much trash that was it it was the one
that was put up or shut up time right so
then after that what did bugger start
talking more dress no he let it just
that was it there was nothing more to
say that's a good one that was a good
one that booger beat SAP yeah but yeah I
can't believe he's gonna be on the
sidelines I can't believe it's Tessa
tour and Whitin we're gonna see yeah we
are gonna see I don't know I don't see
it I don't see it I don't see it just
being honest again I like all three guys
individually I don't know it just
doesn't doesn't seem right but I think
every single broadcast team provides
something different Romo was predicting
plays and also he knew a lot of coaches
and I knew what everyone was doing he's
very knowledgeable about the game I feel
as though Gruden was taking you like so
deep into film study and showing you
plays from three years ago that they
just ran it was incredible yeah Cris
Collinsworth for me his skill set is he
shares amazement yeah every game he goes
I mean come on we need to appreciate
this guy right here like it's like he
was perfect for the Odell catch cuz he
go I really think this is the best catch
I've ever seen he didn't break it down
too much and it's Witten I feel like
he's gonna be trying to do what the Roma
was but I don't even know enough about
what they don't know either I just I
don't know I don't even know enough
about his personality to have any feel
for the situation at all what do you
think about the mike Mayock sand the
Kurt Warner's of the world coming out
and saying I'm never gonna get a chance
to do that even though I have experience
right now okay great I don't really you
know you don't sympathize them because
you kind of you were in that lower tier
of game broadcasters and stuff yeah I
mean it's time to see your ceiling it's
a it's a it's a job that's very much in
demand and if you're not relevant and
and popular and had the right type of
career yeah you're just not gonna get it
so I mean yeah it's Kurt Warner more
qualified than James
certainly but ESPN thinks that people
are gonna enjoy watching Jason wouldn't
more than Kurt Warner they just got to
deal with that same with mike Mayock i
mean mike Mayock of course is so
knowledgeable i'm gonna be able to give
you you know great looks but TV has
become more about football X's and O's
doing games now I mean people seem like
they want personality they want some
normal talk I think that was the great
thing about Tony Romo this year yes he
talked to everybody like we just don't
sit in the ecology normalized right
Nance a lot yes so I mean I from from
all that you know again I just think
Kurt Warner's in the mike Mayock to the
world I think there's a generation out
there that looks at them and just goes
you're kind of boring so do it in a
different style right you know they're
like and well I can't even do it yeah
but I know what you're saying yeah it's
just not I don't think it's sexy enough
to the younger younger crowd there's
what Sims knows the younger demo all
right back to whoa big offseason let's
go to Green Bay this is under better
than expected buzz Mike McCarthy says
DeSean Kaiser would have been a
first-round pick in 2018 Jean Kaiser
doesn't win a game last year but now a
little bit of first-round pick would
have been a first-round pick
I love what do you think you know
propaganda of guys just these comments
that we there's been a few lately where
I want to go like what do you think the
coach is gonna say what is it what else
can he say of course he's in the same
make some random you know what does Sean
Kaiser have in a first-round quarterback
this year maybe cuz more teams needed
more quarterbacks and he would have been
number at least number six on this list
too
he's not as good as the five that got
drafted in the first round yeah I mean
he is everything you want out of the
quarterback except though we talked
about it just not he's not a gifted
natural thrower of the football it's
funny that statement is such a throwaway
statement he'd be a first-round
quarterback yeah but that means that he
would have had to go ahead of Lamar
Jackson because Lamar was the last pick
of the first round that's right so
that's kind of like you saying that
deshone Kizer is better than Lamar
Jackson yeah I think it's a casual
throwaway thing I will say this though
we talked about how the the Jets put
darn 'old in a great spot and how the
Cardinals have Bradford there and the
Ravens have Flacco there and everyone
kind of has a succession yeah and the
Browns have tyrunt
deshaun kinda got thrown to the wolves
definite I've never seen a coach talk
about a rookie quarterback the way that
Hugh Jackson threw DeSean Keizer under
the bus at times last year yeah
blaming him for losses openly like not
even saying we have room to grow here
just kind of like thrashing him
immediately yeah there was no gray
spirit for DeSean Kaiser and I know that
he didn't play great I know that you
didn't have high hopes for him but he
needed new scenery yeah and I think he's
going to be better than he was last year
but I don't think he'll ever be as good
as one of these top five guys I don't
think so either but I I think you're
everything you said I'm with you though
that was a very tough position in a team
that didn't have a lot of town around
him not great receivers I mean we got to
remember that you know our men from
Baylor Josh Gordon he was in there to
the very end yeah Corey Coleman was hurt
so and then yes he was raw and
inconsistent his last year at Notre Dame
so he had to deal with those things
trying to learn on the fly and clean up
some of the technique issues he has
while trying to play in the NFL that's
difficult so huge accidents this week
that Todd Haley has full autonomy of the
offense yes they now have a GM that
doesn't tell Hugh Jackson anything they
have a they have the same defensive
coordinator why
what is Hugh doing now he's given away
all play call he's not involved in
player selection he can't be trusted
with a secret so he's just sort of like
the Statesmen head coach that gives like
the big speeches well he's being a head
coach I mean I you know again he's not
the only guy that I did see I know I
know I'm not saying I know it seems like
all the power keeps being stripped away
from him I just can't believe he's still
the guy yeah well I think we're all
shocked by that yes
Haley coming in is a better offensive
coordinator than Hugh Jackson so it's
I'm happy that Hugh has realized that
and goes okay put your stamp on it I'm
sure he was gonna throw his little two
cents in on a weekly basis same with the
defensive side of the ball but not every
head coach is a game plan designer you
know that and sometimes the beauty of a
real good head coach is just overseeing
and going home this we have an advantage
in this matchup we should attack the
that's how my dad always said Bill
Parcells with Coach he would come in and
be like oh if we have one-on-one out
here with this guy we should throw 20
come back this way they would throw 20
come back stupid exactly right dad would
talk about they get ready to play those
great Eagles teams right and Bill
Parcells and walk in the offensive
meaning the quarterbacks the ovens
coordinated and just start erasing plays
and go we can't block them with these
plays this is ridiculous we can't block
Reggie White and drops that's what it's
downs doing right now exactly right
karthi's kind of there a little bit too
balichek's kind of that guy it's a lot
more clock management it's a lot more
state of the TS it's yeah I just don't
know I know yeah no he's not the guy
right now he's got to prove it to us so
I think you're exactly right with the
question I but but there is a purpose to
what he's doing is what I'm trying to
defend because do you remember when he
got hired it was Hughes perfect he's the
quarterback whisperer right to a team
that doesn't have a quarterback and it's
like well no Todd's talking to him yeah
okay yeah next up for whoa big offseason
on the field reaction buzz had this for
the last few years Patrick mahomes
quotes like wow I've never seen anything
like it
let's go to Baltimore Dateline Baltimore
on one play Lamar Jackson bust through
the line of scrimmage and collided up
the field leaving defenders in his wake
and fifth round receiver Jordan lastly
hollering on the sideline whoa big
offseason big OTA players are yelling
about Mark Jackson oh I love because I
go in Baltimore people are yelling
that's how excited and what John
Harbaugh saw set up to practice the
thing that I was really impressed with
Harbaugh said I thought he was accurate
you read the reports and stuff like that
he's a naturally talented thrower he's
got natural arm talent I think that's
something that people were questioning
to see him out there throwing the ball
naturally and accurately it was a big
plus exciting it's exciting it's
exciting because even though they knew
that he was better than whatever one's
said he's gonna be you still got to see
you you gotta see it and that's what I
love about Baltimore though they don't
give a damn what everybody else says
there's no bias can you play ball do you
love ball are you ready to kick some ass
and be physical then
come join the Ravens that's basically
their motto can I get you more excited
sure various points of practice yeah
Baltimore Iran plays with him lined up
at at multiple positions reminiscent of
Kordell Stewart's slash days in
Pittsburgh with Josh Woodrum playing the
role of Flacco lined up on her Center
and what hardball said is I know you saw
all those plays we're just trying some
stuff in the laboratory great are you
gonna use Lamar awesome what we want is
what we wanted I'm not saying I know I
was one of the first ones to say that
I'm not saying I invented that theory no
but the credit request it was yeah it
was really it was big Phil bill yes from
Bill Cowher having that conversation and
that's where it got into it and I mean
it makes so much sense
and it's great that they're gonna get
him on the field and some other roles
it's only gonna help his development but
I'm just more pumped about natural
thrower accuracy eat that crap unnamed
AFC offensive coordinator who so just
mark my words he guesses when he throws
oh says unnamed wussy ass offensive
coordinator shut your ass up and put
your name by it I do it all the time man
up you know what I hope he does I hope
it was my morning morning wag I didn't
he did it so that the Ravens could drift
hey I'm so annoyed with that it's just a
random person I mean and just like you
know whatever I'm gonna start making up
random people I'm just annoyed about you
know maybe I'm woke as they say but I'm
just by these generalizations of like
yes just a quarterback that's athletic
that he's not a natural tore I mean it
meant the bigger the moment the tougher
the spot just like deshaun Watson the
better the throws are were from Lamar
Jackson that's what I saw so I saw this
clip and I put it on our Instagram Sims
and Lefko of Lamar Jackson getting to
play with himself on Madden and he went
and he looked at his speed he got caught
from behind on a plays like no no no no
no we need to go back and fix this cuz
that's no defensive lineman's catching
me from behind his speed on Madden what
do you think they made him well they
must obviously ripped him off so they
put him in the 80s I'm gonna go say they
made him an 84 88 yeah and I said Lamar
that's the reason we needed you to run
the 40 yeah not for us but so that your
madam Speaker
right right cuz now for the rest of your
career now he's gonna go well we have to
see him run by everybody one time before
we make him a 92 or 93 which is going to
happen in preseason game 1 so don't
worry cuz he's gonna drop back and
they're gonna play action pass and
nobody's gonna be open and he's gonna
break the pocket and run for 65 yards
and the whole league like we've always
joked about seeing goals what didn't I
draft him so what the Lamar Jackson Joe
Flacco thing it made me think we're at a
very interesting time of the NFL where
it's passed the torch season a lot of
quarterbacks are reaching that age
whether it's Eli or Ben or Phillip
Rivers Rainey drew brees all these guys
is there a right way to do it and I'm
seeing different things all over the NFL
and I want to have a discussion about
the aging quarterback dilemma yeah and
not just replacing a Josh McCown right
but replacing a big yeah yeah the hell
would that because those guys like Sam
Bradford like texted Josh Rosen and said
I just want to let you know that I look
forward to playing with you I'll be an
open book if you ever need anything or
any questions feel free to ask hope all
as well Bradford has gone through this
before he's not defending anything he's
ever been in Arizona they're not gonna
build a statue of him it's very much
like dartle to Macau exactly found
reached out to Darnell that was like I
got you bro we're gonna make it was not
a face of the franchise having to hand
over the reins to a new guy not even
like Alex Smith and Patrick Mahone yes
when that happened Alex Smith did reach
out to him and contacted him but Alex
Smith had one year left on his contract
he knew that it was coming to an end
anyway and it actually in my mind
brought the best out of Alex did it made
him very competitive yes but there's two
other situations yes Flacco and Lamar
Jackson right our guy Peter King came
out and said Flacco is definitely
getting the message right he's feeling a
little pressure on him right now Flacco
has not shown up and apparently he is a
little bit upset what is the best way to
handle that with those two guys I don't
I wouldn't bat an eye at it I wouldn't
handle it anyways just coach football
it's not their job to babysit and make
them feel cozy and it's not their job to
make Joe feel secure about his place
when he's played
not great football the last few years
and then was injured on top of that and
they're paying you a ton of money and as
we talked about like with Fletcher Cox
with the Philadelphia Eagles or kendama
consume got cut with the dolphins when
you're the highest-paid guy on the team
you have to do the other things to lead
your football team and I think really
that's what Baltimore is really showing
you that they don't like about Joe
Flacco is he doesn't there's no energy
that he brings to the building on a
daily basis during game day the same way
you don't ever hear stories about Joe
Flacco took his receivers to go throw do
any of that right so there's no
extracurricular leadership and when
you're being paid 28 million dollars a
year
franchises expect that out of you that's
what you do and so he's bringing nothing
if he's not playing well he's bringing
nothing to the table and that's why they
drive to Lamar Jackson I wanted to go
and look back and be like did these
quarterbacks ever have quarterbacks
drafted while they were there and how
did it impact them the only real
quarterback drafted under Joe Flacco was
2011 sixth round pick Tyrod Taylor right
they win the Super Bowl in 2013 I would
say that's when when Flacco started
playing really well it was he was
playing good too before that I this is
Joe father he's never had a second or
third round pick drafted first no you're
right you're right and and and I think
it's so funny to me cuz I looked at
Tyrod Taylor's measurables I mean he's
the same size as Baker Mayfield and he
ran four or five and they go for it yeah
he's got all these but can't get over
yeah so can I was laughing at it as I
was looking at today but the this is the
one thing I'll say about Joe Flacco he
was underappreciated when they were
going to the playoffs and winning
football games and he was outperforming
Brady and some of the other big-time
quarterbacks in the big situations even
the games they lost the New England
28 to 14 right he's not performed really
really Tom in almost all those games
even the one they lost where the
Patriots went to play the Giants the
second time it was a drop touchdown in
the endzone by Evans remember that was
gonna put them in the Super Bowl ey Evan
Lee Evans exactly so um from Wisconsin
nice but I think so he was a lot better
than people gave him credit for in those
days they didn't have an offense that
lend itself to weapons and offensive
side he didn't appreciate him when he
was good right and now we're giving him
a little bit too much credit yeah the
last two years he's began
a little too much credit right I would
agree with that the other one is
interesting yet with Big Ben and Mason
Rudolph Big Ben's saying that he's not
willing to mentor him yeah why did you
why did you use a third-round pick yeah
and Mason Rudolph responded with the way
I responded right I'd probably say the
same thing yes everyone's saying that
Ben is a diva
would you rather the headline Big Ben
I'm gonna stop taking this so seriously
my job now is to groom Mason Rudolph
right there you go that's know if Big
Ben came out with anything other than I
got 4 to 5 years left why did you waste
a pick on him right then I would be more
afraid right Big Ben just threw for over
400 yards and five touchdowns against
the best defense in the NFL he's the
only guy other than maybe Jimmy
Garoppolo but he did it with a little
bit more gimmicks yeah he had his best
playoff game maybe in the last maybe in
his career yeah he put balls on perfect
deep - to Antonio Brown and martavis
Bryant like wonderful and then you're
gonna draft a quarterback in the 3rd
round yeah when you just lost the face
of your defense because of the injury
yeah that this whole week and I hear
people are coming to me going man Big
Ben's a diva and I'm going Big Ben maybe
this is what we're finally gonna get Big
Ben focus yeah maybe this is what we
needed right III don't disagree with
that I mean yeah is like they drafted
them no III hope he's ready to sit on
the bench for the next three to five
years it's like it let a little fire in
them but you can't take Big Ben at his
word either because he does make
comments like I'm gonna evaluate after
the season's over - but my thing is is
if he spent two off seasons ago going I
might retire that means you're chilling
around the house
last season I might have to retire right
did it again you're relaxing now yeah
I'm gonna play three to four more years
right so I kind of get the notion if
you're gonna talk like that yeah then
you better be about that yeah I want
healthier eating I want going to the gym
right you know what I mean like I wonder
if that changes his entire offseason I
hope so
because I mean you know I love he's been
starting slow
he has been starting slow big I love
watching some Big Ben but you're right
the last two years it's been slow
it certainly has about the early the
early games last year I wasn't good
against Minnesota yeah and then towards
the end of the year it's switched back
got on fire uh listen I I love me some
Big Ben as he a diva yes do I appreciate
the fact though that he has real
conversations on the radio about
football and show puts himself out there
like that again I do I really do you
know the organization might not like it
but there's no canned answers like
you're gonna get with some of the other
face of the franchise quarterbacks who
were worried about being political and
making sure everybody likes them yeah
Big Ben don't care and he doesn't care
what the front office of Pittsburgh
thinks about him obviously I mean he
calls them they as in like they're a
separate entity right I looked back they
drafted in the fourth round in 2013
Landry Jones yeah and the fourth round
last year Josh Dobbs right so he hasn't
really felt this high of a pick a
third-round pick hasn't felt this size
when they trade up for Mason Rudolph
Dane did they trace the line it makes it
even more theirs so alright so this is a
good conversation let's have this
conversation I don't even know how I
feel about this but I would say this
right there was some good players on the
board still like the Sam Hubbard's the
Malik Jefferson's Roisin Green from USC
or our big man Orlando Brown
I mean whoever it was they're suppliers
now that could help the football team
also though I look at Pittsburgh and go
well Big Ben does say here evaluates
after every year so that's scary the
power but yeah so he gets a little scary
there I I'll say this too added to that
I mean I understand his side of being
frustrated right because he is coming to
the end and he wants to a third-round
pick and you know there was a lot of
good third-round picks out there this
year that you get a got or maybe they
could have traded up a few picks to get
somebody so this is where I guess I'm
getting to this conversation sorry Eli
Manning the New York Jets have done the
same thing the last two years la Letta
Davis Webb Davis went right there was no
complaints there so again I mean I
understand his side I understand the
organization side this is my main point
though who gives a [ __ ] that's my main
point who gives a [ __ ]
none of these third route tell me that
who's these third round
oh we're drafting our guy in the third
round to be the next face of the
franchise tell me who that is then let
right now you're talking about not
complaining let me introduce you to who
the Patriots have drafted with Tom Brady
since he was there yes
2002 fourth round pick on Rohan Davey
2003 sixth round pick on Kliff Kingsbury
2005 seventh round pick on Matt Cassel
2008 third round pick on Kevin O'Connell
2011 third round pick on Ryan O'Malley
Ryan Mallett 2014 second round pick on
Jimmy Garoppolo 2016 third round pick on
Jacoby % I am a firm believer that when
you have a star and you are eventually
going to pass it along two things happen
one it makes sense to keep drafting
quarterbacks because maybe you'll find
guys that you can trade the Ryan mallets
the Garoppolo is the presets and get
back by or they could end up being the
guy but I think it also keeps your
quarterback motivated now my philosophy
to go from a great quarterback to the
next guy I have a philosophy called a
boy named Sue it's a Johnny Cash song
where Johnny Cash is singing and he's a
man named sue and his entire life he's
been getting the crap kicked out of him
right because people go your name is sue
yeah you have a girl's name and I'm
gonna beat your ass horrible parents
forever the end is a song who names
their kid sue he ends up at the bar yeah
and he realizes that the guy at the bar
was his dad yeah and they get into a
fight and at the end of the fight he
goes that they both realize how strong
the other person is he goes why did you
call him why did you name me that he
goes because I knew I wasn't gonna be
there for you and if I named you sue I
knew you'd be tough because you would
get tough from everyone else and I
wasn't there to make you tough and
that's how I feel
Big Ben is going to train his
replacement the same way that Favre
traded rod trained Rodgers the same way
that Brady trained Garoppolo you want to
be good at this sport watch what I did
have fun ah I'm not sitting here
teaching you crap right copy wet
freaking far if I'm Tom freakin Brady
I'm Brent freakin big freaking Ben Tiger
yes if you want to study me study me
right but I'm not sitting here like Sam
Bradford or Josh McCown and being a good
parent and teaching you what it needs to
be done you're gonna get soft no I mean
it's all I gots my boy named Sue theory
four really good quarterbacks teaching
people under them yeah figure it out
it's not their job you're right they
don't have that and it has nothing to do
with it I mean them being a little
teacher or a leader - oh let me teach
you what I do whatever no you learned by
example you'll learn plenty anybody
seeing how he goes about his daily
routine and that's all that there needs
to be done I'm with you in the fact that
yet you keep quarterbacks around you got
to keep every guy every position
competitive yes certainly and yeah I do
think there's places where they play to
the quarterback see go and they go he
might not be good with another talented
guy here I don't think not only the
Falcons have tried to I know that's why
I want to be like you know well that's
why you have won a Super Bowl either it
just shows you just you know the
toughness is not there from the top down
oh they're worried about their feelings
as their starting quarterback then damn
maybe he shouldn't be your starting
quarterback if your that's why schizo
sicky hearing that and that demon goes
in the rookie quarter oh we can't throw
them out there too early because we
might ruin him well if he gets goes
through a few bad patches and it's
ruined there's first three or four games
of his career then he didn't you made
the wrong pick he shouldn't have been
the quarterback in the beginning but but
I want to just get back to the one thing
the succession plan of the third-round
pick like everybody's like Mason Rudolph
ain't gonna be he's gonna be a backup
quarterback that's the funniest thing
that's just you picked you didn't pick
the guy like he's not around no dropping
let me just alright so you have Tom
Brady right Tom Brady is one of the
outliers of the world and they didn't
pick him to go all we think he's gonna
be the future of franchise they they had
drew blood so they already thought they
had the future they were picking Tom
Brady just going we could use a quality
backup let's see if we can and they hit
they hit dot they hit you know jackpot
okay there's there there's Russell
Wilson who's around pick right but there
was nobody in Seattle they were
literally going into that's Flynn right
let's go with it maybe we'll get Russell
a chance to start he got there the first
day and they're right guys he's the
start of what I call my latchkey kids
right latchkey kids are people they're
your parents are away from working you
kinda have to raise yourselves Russell
Wilson big ben Carson wins yeah you kind
of come in there and it's like
sink or swim yes and and that's just
them being good on their own
yes that's the latchkey right there but
go through the teams here Pittsburgh
top-10 pick franchise quarterback
Jacksonville Jaguars top ten tick
franchise quarterback Kansas City top
ten
franchise quarterback Tennessee Titans
top 10 pick franchise quarterback Oh
Buffalo Bills what do they got oh they
got a new top 10 franchise quarterback
Baltimore Ravens all its top 20
franchise quarterback Chargers top 10
Cincinnati OH top of the second round
Oakland top of the second round top of
the second round right then you've got
the Denver okay they're the one team
that has a career journeyman the Jets
got a franchise Colts franchise Houston
franchise Cleveland franchise you go
through it everybody almost in football
fill it up Viggo's franchise we are at a
very interesting time I saw this on
reddit where the majority of the
quarterbacks in the NFL or either
insanely highly paid or were drafted
there's not a lot of the Case Keenum ZnO
that are like in they never get
developed they never get a chance it
doesn't really it almost has to they
have to have seven shamrocks fly up
their [ __ ] and even get lucky enough
to get called lucky yes I mean it's
literally he had to have so many breaks
to finally get that chance to finally
show what he can that the other one
though was is my perfect parent slash
easing in the fishbowl theory which is
like Warner grooming Eli for like ten
games and then he comes in yeah or
Peterson Doug Peterson with McNabb and
then he came in or with try Biscay where
he came in seven eight weeks yeah that
one like I was doing that with Connor
earlier with Sam darn 'old which is you
look at the schedule you figure out
what's the patch where you want to put
the rookie in and you figure out are
there easy games in the beginning yeah
is there easy games after a bye because
you don't want the first game to be at
Minnesota no I know I looked at the Jets
the Jets I think they might have to
start them right from the beginning
that's like yes or there's a tough
schedule they have a Thursday night game
against the Browns yes but the only
problem is they have to go the next week
on a 10 day schedule they got to go to
Jacksonville that's not where our thing
is if you start darn 'old you get weeks
one two and three and before Jackson
right but there was another time though
where it's like maybe you do it with
McCown or Teddy yeah and see how the
season goes right and then if not just
throw in the last five yeah but that's
that's why carson wentz we were like oh
that makes sense why they're starting
him they started the year against
Cleveland and then played against
Chicago and then after that the schedule
is really really hard
yeah so what has been supposed to say
nothing bad bet it doesn't you know this
situation is different this is not like
Alex Smith who's going oh damn they
drafted a quarterback in the top ten
he's definitely gonna be the quarterback
in the future yeah this is right now a
lot of talk and of course Pittsburgh
just like we were talking about
they made a call while we we had this
guy ranked up there with the other five
call sure you did that's why you passed
them up in the second round right okay
yeah I'm so sick of that crap like no
you did not have him ranked up there
with the top five other guys Ben is the
man there until he says otherwise
I understand both sides that comes back
so skinny I yeah I just want a little
muscle definitions little legs and ass
separation between chin and chest so I
saw this article in The Boston Globe
from Nora Prince IATI and I we always
like to do deep dives on Bella checks
methods because he's Bill Belichick and
he puts importance on things that I
don't often think about and the article
was about how the Patriots love to draft
team captains from their college team
and this year was no different
Isaiah wind Sonne Michelle both
first-round picks both team captains
fifth round pick JaJuan Bentley team
captains sixth round pick
Braxton barrios team captain in New
England's last five draft classes
they've picked of the 42 players
21 collegiate captains it's something
that Belichick is really obsessed with
yeah half of the Patriots starters in
the AFC championship game last year
college captains now it's not always the
case
Jordan Richards was a college captain
too right
but it's just how much stock do you put
in that's it's definitely something that
bill looks at yes because it's important
to him he wants to know that oh these
guys are the team captains why cuz they
felt these teams voted on by he's owned
by the players and the coaches and they
go oh he's here extra he's in the weight
room he does the little things in the
film room he practices hard every day
doesn't matter who we're playing or what
day of the week it is and that's what
Bill wants he wants attention the detail
on a daily basis like we've always said
like no one plays New England goes who
they're so talented how do we
it out in fact everybody plays them and
goes damn how are we still looking up at
the we're losing to these guys that's
good but every interview on Super Bowl
radio row was I think we were more
talented than the piece exactly but they
were just so detailed exactly that's
exactly what they do they just wear you
down with situational football great
schemes no one ever messing up their
assignment and that's what college
captain's do these are guys that are
obsessed with trying to be perfect in
their NFL football world and they bring
that back and I've heard it you know too
many times or recently from New England
people that you know bill is at a point
in his career he just wants to coach
people that he likes and I think love he
doesn't want to deal with any misfits or
a story of every human yeah like I'm at
a point where I only want to hang out
with people that I like yeah I get you
you know when you're younger let me go
to a random bar and stand around and
like meet people and now it's like meet
people yeah
hell no I know he's no new friends build
ship bill bills or coach bill the coach
saves bill the evaluator all the time
yeah all the time
well I sent you the article on Friday
about Bill Belichick being on the phone
with Donald Trump yeah and for the
longest time I was thinking what the
hell are they talking about like what is
the story was too likely talk about Tom
Brady and I'm like is Donald giving him
advice for how to replace people because
Donald's replaced so many people turns
out that Trump is appointing Bill
Belichick to counsel on sports fitness
and nutrition he is one of six athletes
or coaches that are on this council
Simms did you hear the list no I don't
think I've heard the full list oh my god
perfect here are the people that are on
the council
so you have to tell me if you think Bill
Belichick would want to sit and talk
with these people
Mariano Rivera okay that's good one of
course I just
he's been Herschel Walker yeah
volleyball star misty may-treanor right
golfer Natalie Gulbis right who when I
googled her the first thing that came
out with swimsuit issues and a video
series called most beautiful women in
golfing and the last one is dr. oz so
that that forum you think Bella checks
you only really want to sit down and and
talk about sports fitness and nutrition
with those people I have so many things
I could say on the weirdest set bill is
the most I mean first of all I mean very
this is very commonplace of this
administration sorry everybody out there
listen you can throw comments at me I
don't like Donald Trump
I can't even hide it okay so that's
Justin we're gonna go with this but bill
is not qualified to be on that panel I'm
sorry I mean that's just stupid I mean
there's things Bill's great at it like
being in shape is not one of them have
you guys seen Bill Belichick's body I
have with clothes him without it okay
that's just crazy
his workout regime his eating whatever
it is damn I just don't get that 105 are
more qualified than he is so sports
fitness and nutrition he I guess is
gonna handle the sports I guess or I
don't know maybe he'll maybe he'll
spearhead the whole thing and organize
how they should do it you think anytime
I can't imagine I can't imagine this is
just the worst it gets me okay again I'm
sorry everybody out there but we're
going down this road and I got to get it
off my chest
I know Kay good as long as you did it on
purpose then it doesn't make me feel as
bad this is the other thing drives me
crazy about this whole this whole like
relationship I mean this is where I just
don't even understand it and people in
New England are pissed off about this I
know that yes they are there's people
that are pissed that he's like talking
to Donald Trump but he this is where I
go crazy and I think just think it's
like Bill Belichick would never want a
person like Donald Trump on his football
team or in his organization but he's
gonna be friends with them and support
him to run the organization of our
country you mean he would never I mean
he would never an excuse maker who
blames everybody else lies is not
accountable you know basically we'll
just belittle people and make fun of
them for the nobody's ever had on his
organization but yet you're gonna
support him I didn't I don't understand
it it's uh that's where I just go what
like what I do that is one of the most
confusing things to me
you're right though I didn't think about
that I thought about them I didn't know
what the council was going to talk about
so I am
like sharing their experience but like
Mariano Rivera misty may-treanor no
talker dr. oz and Natalie Gulbis are
gonna come in and be like Adonis yeah
we're like we're the best athletes you
see yes and then Belichick is kind of
like waddle in yeah I just don't get it
with this backpack this backpack exactly
right maybe you know let some cutoff
hoodie sweatshirt or something but yeah
that one is all crazy the faculty hired
Bella checked for that is not that crazy
I mean I can understand that to a degree
its validity but I don't understand the
friendship and the supporting a guy that
of course is a lot of guys on his team
think you know the president has been
disrespectful to them yeah I just
thought it was a joke I know you get
fired up guy now all right slow news day
these are stories that shouldn't be
stories but it's July so their stories
never an out yes okay Sam darn 'old
fumbled the first to snap of T my bust
back to Southern Cal where the Senators
butt crack is going put your middle
finger in between the two balls okay I'd
like to remind everybody that true
Biscay fumbled three snaps in one
practice drill last summer it's over
it's just when we start doing live
tweeting of rookie minicamp right and
we're going great throw by thereby
Darnell I think he's gonna be a good
pick on like the center quarterback
center snap exchange with the center
that's been a right tackle his whole
career and now he's snapping the ball
because they don't have centers and the
rookie OTA my finger first snap fumbled
my first nap on my Tampa Bay career
minicamp Brook first one had a guy that
never percent snapped it snapped it
short finger out of the socket yes did
you miss the rest of practice so I
sucked it up and popped it back in
through lasers and it was yeah how much
does that hurt it hurt so did you look
at the guy you are you an idiot
no I just like I was like in Gruden's
like I heard
it was a diva they popped it in and that
was it
does it hurt after the fact yeah gift
like what I sit down yeah you tape it I
sit down yeah because that's the thing
when I'm watching sports and I see a guy
like dislocated shoulder I'm like
process it's yes it's pop it in the
first time I had done the finger a few
times before that so it was loose to
begin with but yeah it's a weird feeling
because you go oh wait oh that hurt and
then you start to go oh wait something
doesn't feel right and you look at it
and you go what though it's making a
90-degree turn here and I can't clench
my fingers or do anything cuz it's like
stuck and then you just gotta sit there
and kind of grit your teeth so
somebody's the same thing it's I always
see the quarterback facing to the right
and his hands behind him and they're all
around they're like holding his arm and
he's like exactly that's right it's like
Arnold money that gets onto them Mars
alright so another one slow news day
stories that shouldn't be stories but
it's July so it's a story Josh Rosen is
texting Patrick Peterson too much quote
Patrick Peterson it was like a ten page
message I'm like why are you texting me
this I'm freakin enjoying dinner with my
wife right now Rosen hasn't stopped
texting since asking Peterson questions
about topics ranging from finding a good
realtor to taking care of his body
through the season josh has been texting
me like there's no tomorrow
Pat Beach said I'm trying to get him
with a realtor so he has a place to lay
his head
I'm excited he wants to be a leader
early that's huge when a young player
comes to leading grabs an older guy and
tries to learn his way around but I just
love the fact that Patrick ages ago
leave me be like you gotta toed the line
as a rookie can't annoyed the vets right
you need to show that you care that you
want to ask questions but you can't
overdo it right because then they're
gonna look like damn you just a rookie
and yeah we're not best friends yet I
mean you ain't been in the locker room
yet we haven't been the shower together
yet you gotta get that shut up you
texted me too much well it's just funny
because when we had Emmitt Smith in here
and I was like I want to talk about your
Arizona Cardinal days yeah and he was
like man Larry was just a sponge he
wanted to know everything and I go
aren't all rookies like that and he
started
and he goes no no so many who don't
think they know everything already but
that's what's so funny I know I love
being the fan in our conversations
because I'm going know like Sam darn
old's getting mentored by Josh McCown
they sit down every day they go over the
playbook occasionally they have wine and
pizza together like it's a relationship
but apparently these young kids come in
and think they're already hot [ __ ] I
didn't know that yeah definitely yes
there is it I thought everybody was
learning I thought it was always a
mentor process for the most part I mean
if you get 10 brookey's usually seven to
eight of them are really good and want
to do everything right and then there's
a few that are just like I'm not sure if
he loves this or and he thinks he's got
it all figured out or he's just
extremely quiet and that's just the way
he is and then you realize oh he does
love it and he's willing to work at it
just as like a quiet personality
altogether do you think it's like the
new high school thing where you don't
want to ask questions cuz you want
people to think that you know what the
hell you're talking about
but you actually need to ask the
questions I think a lot of the times the
guys that are clueless when they come in
they think they got to figure it out and
they think I'm just gonna go out in the
field and ball cuz that's what I've
always done and they just don't realize
what they're getting into and that like
no Patrick Peterson's been balling every
day he's he's quite baller ish and he
does all these other things every day to
become a better player and it's just if
you don't have the right mindset and the
you know the humbleness to listen and
work and do all those things it's hard
to grow um Matt Ryan Matt Ryan hundred
million dollars guaranteed 30 million
per season forty six point five million
dollar signing bonus he signs a
five-year contract and he's turning 33
and ten days is it deserved yes
okay this desert that's fair yeah I
wasn't asking that for you to give it a
no no I know it's it's deserved is it
deserve does it like does Aaron Rodgers
and Russell Wilson and Tom Brady deserve
I have one question here is is Aaron
Rodgers getting a billion dollars
I mean I actually thought the first guy
I thought of was Tom Brady
is that weird no I just cuz I was like
man if there's anybody that should be
pissed off right it you talking about
the guy who I dominated two years ago in
the Super Bowl it had a twenty eight to
three lean on me and I'm gonna make half
as much money as him and I just won the
MVP and I don't have Julio Jones and
some Devonta Freeman and seven called me
right and some of those guys so to me
again I know people think I'm a Tom
Brady hater I'm not I'm a very realistic
in right away you think of the resume I
think of what he's accomplished and how
he's no good right now right and just
everything yeah my other thought was man
it really sucks that Aaron Rodgers plays
for a team that doesn't have one owner
so that he can't get any money slid
under the table when you play for the
Packers you need to be by the books you
know Arthur Blank may have cut Matt Ryan
a little Tom Brady might be getting that
that secret craft money oh yeah I would
think Belichick and Brady are getting
secretly paid through other avenues
Aaron Rodgers is taking the good money
of the people of of Wisconsin yes he is
of the Green Bay investors the Packer
investors I know it's it's a different
dynamic up there it's what makes us
special but yeah I mean to me right I
mean if we just get into Rogers right
Rogers and Russell Wilson's getting down
to the end here too which was you know
again that was one of the more
disrespectful quarterback deals we've
seen for years eighty million for a guy
that went to the Super Bowl twice and
now is like the greatest one-man show on
the sport other than Rodgers that
offseason though was the same offseason
that Colin Kaepernick to the took the a
year I forgot about that they both took
team friendly deals because they were
both young quarterbacks who always were
the news for because they're on a rookie
contract they can they can acquire all
this talent and Russell Wilson took less
money so Bennett got paid and cam got
paid and I'll Thomas got paid Richard
Sherman got paid and they still hate it
exactly you Russell Wilson took a
contract for them and they still thought
he was corny and made rifle and played
future in the locker right right Dave
and he's there and he was the reason
they won last year and he did all that
and he's way better than and the most
important he might
the most important player to any
franchise right now he might be the most
important like it simmer Rodgers but
yeah I just I mean when you think of
Rodgers to like Rodgers has got to look
at that and go no no I don't like one-up
this by like a million like this this
you think I'm gonna get like a hundred
and one million guaranteed like there's
no way you're Matt Ryan is not one of
the five best quarterbacks in football
for me
he's definitely towards the eight nine
ten range I mean Aaron Rodgers I don't
think anybody the people who hate Aaron
Rodgers go he's definitely at least top
to their top three if we're gonna be
really me yeah and I just go whoa I mean
he's gonna get paid but it's never paid
based off of talent no it's not I mean a
lot of the time we also see it the other
way to where guys get paid for what they
have done like we argue about all the
time yeah that's funny so you you saw
the Matt Ryan contract and thought oh
brain I thought I saw the Matt Ryan
contract and thought of Roger yes yeah I
did I know right both of them are
getting screwed right now as far as
marketing I like the last few
highest-paid quarterbacks in the NFL
have been Alex Smith Kirk Cousins Matt
Ryan Derek yeah and it's like men yeah I
know
I mean staffer people like I'm Stanford
was high family I can understand that I
know but a lot of bacon I know I love
what's going on right now on the Chiefs
Raiders rivalry Chiefs go out there in
the draft and draft Khalil McKenzie
Reggie Mackenzie's son right it's a play
defensive line and it's like whoa like
it's like someone stealing Austin Rivers
from Doc and the Chiefs came back this
week or the Raiders came back and signed
Derek Johnson yeah from the cheese
that's cool google rivalry that will be
a grain that's Andy and John who have a
coaching history together right Andy was
the quarterbacks coach in Green Bay John
was like the wide receivers right John
was a wide receivers coach yeah
interesting all these great minds that
they're coached a wide receiver yeah
you're right it's interesting it is very
interesting year the Eli Manning quote
about Eagles fans
speaking of rivalries Eli Manning says
he loves playing in every NFL stadium
but Philly takes a while to get used to
because it's not easy seeing a
nine-year-old in the stands cursing at
you and talking about my mom yes yet
proof that the Eagles fans are the best
of
boys that's what you know what that is
really something we should do for our
Wednesday Thursday show we've never
really asked big Phil his experiences
with the Philly fans we haven't but I
don't know I don't remember it I know
we've got some good stories cuz of
course they they they had the Giants
ways down there in Philly even when the
Giants are awesome and I've heard of
them like briefly tell stories a few
times here's what I want to do yeah Phil
needs a homework assignment yeah
tell Phil to think of some great stories
of interacting with Eagles fans okay so
that when he comes on the show Wednesday
he can be like oh I thought of something
you guys would absolutely love you're
gonna love this one left going you're
gonna love this one okay cuz he's like I
don't know he's got a few I know towards
the end of his career like one of those
years when he had a bet like backup Jeff
Hostetler and I know he's got a few like
there where they were razzing them hard
and man he gave it back that's awesome
alright so we are gonna go now to an
interview with Minka Fitzpatrick on the
phone taking 11th overall with the Miami
Dolphins good kid we'll break it down
afterwards but this is our conversation
with Minka Fitzpatrick that professional
Minka so nice wow you are versatile
there right
yo Minka what's good this is Simpson
left co bleacher report I just wanted a
vol-au-vent up jars right so we're
starting the interview just started we
started but yeah I'm a Jersey guy I
watched you play in high school
I saw your pic six against Paramus
Catholic to win it all so it's about
time you got drafted high in there in
the first round because I'm sick of
pumping you for your even waiting for it
man high school BC BC Bosco audience
yeah like I said it's cool that
in everything come to fruition now it
really is well you know speak about just
New Jersey football a little bit because
I'm interested in the fact that you know
you're a little bit like me I went to
Texas being from Jersey you go to
Alabama when you went down there where
guys like come on Jersey can't play any
ball but then you did you name some of
the names that were in your state
championship game and things like that
to give it a little you know street cred
oh you never saw I don't know the
biggest thing I heard this show you know
[Music]
with the guy so like no pay that much
attention to it when it comes to
football but in the league right now
he's like a guy yeah there are real good
players that are out there I mean you
wouldn't even know the difference
because we don't talk about it online
yeah and nobody goes to college in New
Jersey yeah like a lot of people think
like people in Louisiana because I was a
family right I know I know like I myself
was my second with me people don't know
right yeah I'll tell you what there's
not a lot of guys though that become
Nick Saban's favorite player and I'm
reading everywhere I do it I was like
how is this guy not going in the top six
because I go this is saving son Sims
that was the nickname that his teammates
gave him was Saban son and I'm just
curious Megahouse dad how's Nick he
liking a lot of people not a lot of
people got their their side because I
worked hard
yeah did my job you know trouble
do so he did confine them he had
different types of conversations because
I want ours is a different level
maturity and I did talking about certain
things on the field you know
no we had to spend a lot of time because
that is going to hold our positions and
plays and Kazakh stuff like that because
I move around someone song we spend a
little extra time again in the film room
so I just had a different type of
relationship so that's what it was it
was the personal bond and the thorah
because I was gonna say do you realize
that you're the OL and improve me wrong
but you're the only one I can remember
in recent history where he actually
stood on a pedestal
it was incredibly talked about you as
everybody's undervaluing you and you
should be a top five pick did you
recognize kind of that's different for
him to do that you know my parents I
brought too much attention but you know
there is a kind of ed with norm
all right immediately know it doesn't
like the bigger place our players to my
head I think that's amazing why don't we
do is because not you know some players
kind of take it as a as a reason it's
like off but I think he knew that I was
I wouldn't take it and to get complacent
while taking more as a reason to just
back up his work no but you're in the
mid level yeah Minka I got a personal
question for you so my dad did
refrigeration and air conditioning and
for me that was kind of like always a
motivation for me like kind of know
where I came from
it's like the family business and I know
your dad was a truck mechanic and I'm
curious like did you ever do you ever
feel that helping you out do you ever
like think about that or use that 13
years old so I knew exactly was it
whether it was in construction or just
sometimes we do plumbing or being
mechanic but you know mechanic was his
main job necessarily for the most part
you know it was not an easy job oh you
definitely don't get nothing what you
put in
you know there's me uh so like when I'm
sitting on the truck and it's enough
power to power transmission without 14
years old it wasn't fun at all you know
and uh you know you know I just use that
like you said instead of all the faces
just keep working keep doing I got a do
stay focused and then maybe one day I
wouldn't have to work as work that I
mean work that type of job all right so
I don't know bull crap here straight
Jersey to Jersey here okay don't get me
any of that bull crap I'll come find you
in New Jersey and let you whip my ass
for this case but either way okay what
position is Minka Fitzpatrick what
position position are you best at I want
to know what position you are okay yeah
you are a football player kind of keep
my mind around it i watch the spin 1 c1
supposed to look at you like this does
it bother you that you really you're
incredible versatility in college
football almost ended up hurting you in
the NFL Draft process at first it was
like oh look at he's so versatile then
it became oh well we're not sure what
exactly position he is were you kind of
bothered by that overanalyzed I don't
know yeah over analyze I'm good at
whatever pretty pivotal positions
playing no I play them all at a high
level I don't have a pen I could
complicated system that's why people
just over analyzing the whole thing like
I never played out of position didn't
play well I'll add it didn't feel good
enough job to have my country's not
playing here so I think that people just
over analyzing it making a bigger deal
out of it than what it should have been
and you know whether my grooming place
whether that be a corner and inside
corner and Satan
I'm gonna do latitude in my job play you
know this is something I just emphasize
the coaches when they're asking I did a
rising same things you think you would
even Archie drawers are moving around
and stuff like that I said no is
wherever you boom those in my place and
I know the end of Alabama right I'm
gonna have more grips I'm gonna have
more time to study quantity so I'm gonna
have time study for our had more time
studying my opponent because I'm not
studying what I yeah in to get develop
more and more yeah yeah I want to thank
JCPenney for making this interview
possible yeah at Alabama
he played boundary corner slot corner
free safety safety and linebacker and I
feel like from like what I hear his
answer the Dolphins are like you know
how you would be in the new in the film
room with Saban and you studied all of
them senior the whole defense just just
do the same thing like I think the
dolphins are like no we're not gonna put
you know one just just do exactly what
you did which it's cut to go 11th
overall man you're kind of a leader now
can you feel that even though you're so
young in that new locker room
in terms of like you're gonna be the
fresh face in the locker room but
because you got taken where you're
taking you're gonna have to be one of
the leaders how do you approach that
balance myself no no I can't walk in
there and some people will do because
member young guys for Spain yeah you
know he's gonna be myself you know earn
respect of the vets and my other
teammates going there sitting and
working hard and you know basically oh
I'm gonna have to develop leadership
roles because that's my personality you
know and like you said where I got that
I had to have leadership Rose go oh no
when that when that time comes it comes
I'm not trying to rush it I'm just
trying to establish myself and with my
teammates my coaches
SEC football is a beast it's the best
conference of college football you
played against some pretty talented guys
the last few years in that conference I
want to know like somebody that jumped
out to you just who you played in
college for
ball probably in the NFL now or maybe
still in college football but who was
the guy to you where you were like wow
that was a different animal is it
Leonard fournette is it Sony Michelle
from this year but I just be interested
to hear who that guy was for you know a
couple different guys I mean my freshman
job was a great player from running back
right of course like you said Leonard
fournette was a great run it back we
sell receivers from Ole Miss Treadwell
yeah yeah right the trip well he yep
Christian cards on them selfs I think
this versatile been amazing plays do you
believe in the cold like question of
like Alabama guys are already beat up
before they get to the NFL like you're
already on your last leg because Nick
Saban worked you guys so hard that's
always kind of a common theme so I hear
that all the time and I just I'd love to
hear your perspective get our bodies
right they know these killers and break
this down to the point where we can't
play the already played in it'll be
pointless the work is hard so they work
as hard with at the same time like
physical therapy team in athletic
training team across the country
whenever we have someone get hurt
they're back away before they're said to
be back and you know we have little mix
of bruises and they fix it up real quick
and they'd like day whenever sore we
never cover stuffers every single day
after practice our awesome account so
you know that I don't believe that I
feel great right now Josie everybody's
been hurt ang great football right but
you know I think they've done a great
job of getting us back healthy making
sure we're feeling right things so we're
eating right doing the right things so
I'll believe that all right you could
ask any business in the league right now
Velma so you go dress
night and you're looking fresh and I
know that JCPenney hooked it up but I'm
just curious
what is the process in picking the draft
suit and what was that night for you
like as a whole so designers came to
Tuscaloosa Alabama different things it's
on back so we just really in my pants
and its designers it's kind of put
something together piece by piece and
then you can go to like the last two
days JCPenney designer shoes like I seen
his buttons that would look beautiful
jacket she told me they're not like star
mining can so she put them on there so
cool so you're telling me that so you're
telling me you wore a suit that was
different pieces kind of all put
together so in essence it was a Mickey
Fitzpatrick suit now what do you think I
mean it's South Beach attire it's like
he knew you dolphins were gonna it's
like getting ready to go out with like
Don Johnson and what the hell is that
Miami Vice sorry so that's my last
question for you cuz I know you got crap
to do and you got money to make with
JCPenney but this is did you think the
Dolphins were I know you just said it
you know but who-who before the Dolphins
who did you think was gonna take you
where did your gut tell you you know
leading up to draft night really no idea
good luck team can't they can't tell you
so much could change up so that when
they can't promise y'all can take here
when if they're available but not if you
say go their needs might change
so they can't tell you nothing really so
use it less like up in the air and then
I saw I was sitting there are thousands
like beauty pieces in the window where
you know guys I had no clue that stuff
gonna take me so I only talk to my
talking with compound and that's how to
code in the DB coach right just one or
two times before and right now all right
so what is it like we this has happened
the last few years where there's one
position group that has two guys that
are kind of better than everybody else
that happened this year with safeties
with you and Erwin James I'm sure you'll
like Derwin James I'm sure when you've
seen him on tape you have been impressed
what is it like when you know that okay
we're the top two safeties and I'm kind
of battling it out with him what does
that become during that process you know
he think he's a better plan I think I'm
a better player so is this you gotta let
the coaches decide what is what and he
knows this you know I like I see these
great players are spending 1% great do
dogs for you I would talk a lot of time
with everyone together but but you know
it's not much we could do you know
there's a way the whole thing is just a
waiting game but you could do all the
different stuff but then the day is
waiting for some of the others to make
decisions somebody else made a call I
mean he's got to be in there in a jiffy
yourself and of course it's working
harder and harder process what is your
advice for Minka because he's got some
camps he's got some rookie cams coming
up you were a rookie once he had to go
in the locker room and talk to Warren
Sapp and explain yourself what do you
tell Minka what's your sim sage advice I
say it really it's continue to be who
you are which I know is work at football
only worry about football and make that
your main focus and don't get caught up
in all the other stuff that's off the
field be humble in the locker room
that's how the vets will respect you and
watch out for South Beach because
there's a lot of things you can get into
trouble with
i I how doesn't say make a Fitzpatrick
ain't going near some right a
Lamborghini hey man have fun man I'm
rooting for you we're both rootin for ya
go Jersey kick some ass down there man
pick off Tom Brady that'll be a lot of
fun thank you to JCPenney Mickey you're
the man bro have a good one man
see you buddy
mica is off the line I mean he's
everything in here yeah Johnny
professional yeah he really is I know I
would love to get around him a little
bit cuz I think he's the kind of guy we
could have fun with to the concept of
Nick Saban yeah
liking a player so much that he openly
tells the player that I like you more
than other players when Nick talks to
everybody like they're the same that's
interesting it's like his little his his
baby his position that's his baby is
DB's right that's where he's an expert
and then he got this guy that all of a
sudden not only is talented but oh crap
I can entrust them with a lot of
different things to get the backend
orchestrated all the time and he became
like an extent it sounds like he became
an extension of the coaching staff
almost the Nick Saban like Nick was in
private meetings with him to go hey if
you see this check to this and he does
see no it's the rare situation where you
have a guy that gets so much love from
the coach yeah but still doesn't
alienate himself from the locker room
right which has to be freaking hard yes
because you know he's going he's always
the coach he's always right and when
you're a college kid for sure yeah I'm
not trying to have someone my age tell
me what to do well they probably know I
mean his examples at that point have
probably set the record straight right
you know just suggest they've seen the
guy he's he doesn't [ __ ] doesn't lie
he works hard he's not trying to kiss
anybody's ass to become the coach's pet
any of that stuff yeah so they see it
and they go damn Saban just likes him
better than us we just got to deal with
it and we're gonna he's still our guy I
was gonna ask him but I figured it would
go too serious of a turn
his family got displaced on Hurricane
Irene oh and him and four of his
siblings and his parents had to live in
his grandparents basement for a little
bit and I'm curious like I never lived
with my grandparents yeah I know a lot
of people who were raised by their
grandparents or grew up with a
grandparent living in the home lot of
them the NFL and grandparents have
freaking gyms yeah you know what I mean
like when you around your grandparents
it's like here's a gem about life right
grandma must give it to me on Saturday
when I was on the porch in 1924 but not
even that you ever your be around your
grandparents and they're just like Adam
whatever makes you happy do that ever
and you're like it's the simplest advice
but grandma you're always right right
I've Minka feels like he hung around his
grandparents he's an old soul you know
yeah you could tell it and you can hear
it it's funny because we go through the
bakers and the Josh Rosen's and we
wonder are they really mature enough you
know all this stuff right and then I got
like Minka it's almost like easy to
mature yeah you know as he maxed out
he's the most mature guy from the school
that we often concern ourselves with
maturing guys yeah it's right he is the
most he's the rapist pineapple I think
the thing he'd the point he made is what
he should have been telling teams all
along and hopefully what I have personal
film room so she's Nick Sabol that and
the fact that he's getting to say like
I'd like he said at the one point
they're not gonna move me around as much
in the NFL so I'll be able to focus in
on one position and practice that those
reps from what that looks like I don't
do that he's like I think he's gonna
play every one of these positions I
don't think he's on a bike corner corner
like outside corner yeah that would be
the one I would say no but I think the
other stuff yeah I'm with you I think
you know you start them off at free
safety you get them going there after a
few weeks they go okay here's the nickel
package get them comfortable
you'll see them bounce back between
their and they're calling the plays by
the end of it definitely all right guys
thank you so much hope you enjoyed the
podcast and then of course we're
recording this here I'm just going to do
this now then yeah you are gonna have to
do it no men in the podcast with this in
terms of the mascot battle uh
I always do in the show so we have to do
it here I need you to pick a number
between as I pull it up between one two
three four five six seven seven one
through seven let's go with John Elway
number seven number seven oh I'm very
excited
wednesday's mascot battle would you like
the first one or the second one give me
the first one and then i'll guess the
second one no this has been submitted
from gjj NJ v sims will be representing
a giant haha and i will be representing
a jet like donkey kong king kong yeah
yeah okay you don't get into it now
small little jet that flies around
that's nice it's cute yeah guess what
enough for wednesday big phil will bring
it down yeah i got a little bit sad when
I heard his interview again and he was
like you know I had all this information
on traffic and nobody called me
and then boomers like giraffe tweaks
like porn for him I was like we need to
be Phil's outlet all right guys love you
so much we'll be back on a Wednesday
night Thursday morning for Sims peace
out homey federic says good evening
everyone and the lef koe man says good
night
love you talk to you soon peace